we've lifted the lid on the Android
studio box and pulled out instant run a
fast and shiny new emulator a new GPU
profiler and all the new features and
improvements of IntelliJ 15 I'm reto
Meier its Android tool time time and
this is Android studio 2.0 instant run
is a new feature that once enabled lets
you build and deploy incremental changes
your app within a few seconds
dramatically improving the speed of your
test and debug cycles once you have your
app up and running hitting instant run
after making code changes such as
changing this chess board from 2d to 3d
and modifying the size and color of the
pieces will perform a hot swap sending
only the changed code to your app the
affected methods are overridden and your
code changes are applied in real time
within the running app instance hot
swapping works by injecting code where
you make changes your app isn't
restarted so memory allocations remain
unchanged meaning class initializers
won't be rerun and static variables are
initialized existing instances and
constructs like fields and single syns
are left untouched changing resources
such as editing colors strings or even
layouts will send the modified resources
file to the running app and you'll be
able to see it when the activity is
restarted called a warm swap which will
do for you automatically if we detect
that it's necessary some changes such as
modifying your manifest or changing
layered IDs currently trigger a full
build exactly which changes will cause a
full rebuild versus a called or warm
swap will change as instant run improves
and evolves so rather than listing them
here in detail and having this video
become quickly updated you can find the
details in the docs instant run works
with all emulators in every recent
physical device in fact on every
platform version all the way back to Ice
Cream Sandwich not content with instant
run Android studio 2.0 also improves
each step of the full build and deploy
process so even full builds happen more
than two and a half times faster the
first time you hit run or debug for your
code or each time you do a clean build
the code is compiled and converted to
Dex files is optionally shrunk optimized
and obfuscated with ProGuard and has its
classes and resources packaged all
before it's uploaded to the device and
installed Android studio to point
has improved each of these steps
starting with the X we've reduced time
here by over half primarily through
improving the DX merger algorithm now
that merging Dex dependency modules is
lightning fast we gain significant gains
from pre-dexing them and not read Xing
them if they haven't changed so if your
project has a lot of modules you'll see
significant gains here
we've also modified the X so that it now
runs in process and you can specify
running up to four DX instances in
parallel this has significant advantages
as we no longer start a new VM for each
DX instance giving the JIT more
opportunity to optimize code and
removing the overhead of starting and
running multiple parallel VM instances
if you're using ProGuard it creates a
single jar that effectively disables the
pre-dexing advantages that we just
gained so we developed a new shrinker to
use in debug builds it doesn't replace
ProGuard it just replaces it's shrinking
functionality so you still need to run
pro guard on release builds to optimize
and obfuscate your code but for
debugging the shrinker isn't much faster
by including some incremental support
and critically by not read Xing
dependencies to improve double apt
packaging times on full builds we now
ask you to select a deploy target before
your apt is built
we'll check what resources are required
for that particular device for example
initially we'll only package and push
the appropriate image resource
resolutions and future Android studio
releases we'll expand that to include
resources such as abis and legacy multi
decks to improve deploy times we improve
the ADB push-pull protocol making it
very fast a deploy to an emulator which
seems like a really good reason to
improve the emulator UX and make it
really really ridiculously fast in fact
running the new emulator are typical def
hardware is faster than using a physical
Android device to achieve this we've
added SMP support to take advantage of
host multi-core architecture and
optimize GPU i/o and CPU performance at
the same time we completely rebuilt the
emulator UI it now includes a toolbar to
enable actions like screen rotation and
screenshots and support for deploying
apks through drag and drop you can
rescale the emulator frame by dragging a
corner modify a device hardware changes
like GP
cellular network conditions battery
state and incoming phone calls or texts
we've also made it easier to keep up to
date the IDE will prompt you when
there's a new emulator available for you
to download if you're building something
graphics-intensive like a game you can
take advantage of a new GPU profiler and
debugger it lets you record and replay
the entire GPU stream frame-by-frame
allowing you to inspect the GPU state at
each stage and help you understand what
caused each specific rendering outcome
you can select an individual frame by
either the top bar or the GPU commands
panel once you select a frame the frame
buffer window will update to show that
frames contents you can also see and
inspect each individual command + GL
call that was used you can also use the
GPU state window or the textures tab to
explore GPU state at the time of your
selected frame or draw calls enter a
Studio 2.0 is built on IntelliJ 15 which
offers improved stability and a number
of new features including improvements
to the built in integrations with
version control systems such as support
for rebase on git and cool new features
like finding path and distraction free
mode there's also a unified user
interface for testing that includes a
test runner tool window inline
statistics and a test result history
we've built on top of those test
improvements allowing you to have both
Android and unit tests or sets active
while you develop enabling refactorings
across those source sets we've also
worked closely with Google search to
make it easy to create deep links within
your app including static code
inspections to check that your links are
correctly configured and real-time
testing to confirm Google can index and
render your app pages correctly
episodes of Android tool time will dive
deeper into these and other new features
from Android studio so subscribe to
Android developers on youtube and check
out the Android tool time playlist and
remember if you've been taking your
breaks based on building and deploying
your app you may want to start setting
alarm to remind you to eat and drink at
regular intervals
that's Android studio 2.0 and this was
Andrew at tool time time